i got a nice little segment here for you
since people love ronnie's stuff and we
decided to
take pictures of women who are from
ronnie's generation you know ronnie's in
his 70s now yeah he's a ladies man and
he's always given sex tips and stuff so
we said let's give him something fun to
do so we gave him pictures of women when
they were young
who would now be his contemporaries okay
well ronnie i want to tell you something
there's a little twist to the story
i can imagine
are you sitting down
yeah i'm sitting down of course
we recorded you giving the evaluations
of these women the pictures we showed
you but what you didn't know
is that all of those women
were members of our staff's mothers oh
jesus
but what
are you kidding
me
he saw them pics now he wants to catch
his
it may be strong but ronnie's raping
zappers
what i'm going to reveal to you now
ronnie as we play your graphic
descriptions of what you would evaluate
these women and what you would do to
them
know that this is either gary delabate
jason kaplan john blitt will murray
wolfie sal governali and mike fox's
mothers
okay
whatever
ah you stand by what you said huh yeah
i don't care this first mama this is a
jason's mom
amazing lips i mean there is definitely
a [ __ ] there
small boobs she's got a decent body i
mean she's got she's wearing a mini
dress and you know her legs look good
she looks like she's probably got a nice
[ __ ] she's sexy in her own way now
other people would probably disagree
with me but she's got a look that you
know she she wants play she wants to
have a good time
she's wearing the black stockings which
is back in the day was a hot thing i
just think she she looked like she'd
probably taken the ass
and uh
you could have you could have a lot of
fun with this girl not not the most
beautiful girl but very sexy in her own
way i would give her a seven definitely
give her a seven and what is it like
jason to hear ronnie saying your
mother's very [ __ ] her ass looks
like it would be wide open well is it a
creepy feeling to hear ronnie talk
it's such a mixed bag yes it's creepy
i'm also happy he didn't be he wasn't
like oh she's disgusting and gross and
stuff that would have felt bad for my
mom so i'm happy to get past that but
yeah i mean he talked about my mom's
blow job
yeah well just just think about who
thought about this [ __ ] idea to do
this
but my mom and i do have the same face
so when he talks about her lips and what
they look like they can do it's just
gross on several levels you would [ __ ]
her in the ass and uh she looks like she
gives her you heard my review dude i'm
not taking it back that's right she
looks like she wants to have fun
i would chew on her pubes like a billy
goat eating grass
all right ronnie didn't know this but
the next picture is she's very cute
she's got that cutie pie face it looks
like she has a little boobies but that's
cool
doesn't matter she's got a cute smile
sitting here in the chair she looks she
got that nice big butt i think she would
take it in the ass for sure and she
would still have that big smile on her
face too i think on a one-to-ten scale i
would give her a six but in bed i would
give her a nine
overall seven
ronnie that is my mom
yeah
i would i wouldn't i would have never
guessed that one
but i think i want wolfie to blow me now
ronnie how do you know from looking at a
picture of wolfie's mom that she wants
it in the ass like how can you tell like
what is because you're the sex expert i
don't know man she just just has that
cutie pie look that she's up for
anything no no offense wolfie yeah
not that that hot hot looking girl but
she's that cute girl that really wants
to prove something to the guy she's with
yeah
all right our third mom she looks like
she could be fun but i don't think so
she's hiding a lot of things
um big giant glasses to hide basically
hide her face kind of like nothing
low-cut
she's just seems like a plain jane
trying to be cool i don't think she
would be fun in the bedroom i think
she's trying too hard to look cool as
much as she's trying i think she would
be a cold fish in bed nah she wouldn't
be cool in the bed scaling one to ten i
would probably give her
five
just trash blitz mother you know what in
my head maybe subconsciously i knew it
was blitz mom mm-hmm right
because i always [ __ ] with my head all
the time so john do you think your mom
is a sexual a wild animal and ronnie has
it all wronger she is a while that's
what i've heard actually from guys she's
been with that she is incredible in bed
and i want ronnie to have sex with her
try her i'll ask stephanie if stephanie
gives the go-ahead
please
i'm now going to present to you the
fourth mom that ronnie evaluated without
knowing that it was someone's mom
she's very plain
very
matron-looking kind of look they're fun
in bed they they aim to please
she has nice hands looks like a great
hand job uh small boobs so she would let
you do anything pretty much to her boobs
over it you could jerk off on him
probably you could do it you know
whatever i think she she would be up for
anything
so my overall score between one and ten
on her would definitely be
a seven
is that sal's mom correct it's right it
is sal's mom the day i recorded this
with him howard i felt the blood just
leave my face you know what i mean
to hear him talk about my mom giving
good hand jobs and would love loads on
her tits
it was just uncomfortable
it's true and are you secretly sitting
there going i just hope he doesn't trash
my mother i would have taken him
trashing my mother i rather he would
have said ah you know what she's ugly i
don't want a banger versus i would love
to drop a load on her chest
you know she's got hands that could give
a great hand job
it was just oh god here's ronnie's
evaluation of this mom the fifth mom
this chick is like
your girl that went to the all-girl
catholic school the type that as soon as
she got out of school she would get off
the bus she'd be in her little uniform
and we'd run right to my [ __ ] house
man and we would get at it right away
she'd be horny and hot you want to
finger me make me come go ahead you want
to play with my [ __ ] go ahead you
want to suck on my boobs go ahead and
i'm ready to do anything
i say i can't wait to get into bed with
you this is the chick that does it all i
guarantee uh i would give her a seven
and a half for the cuteness and
definitely the fun in bed
ronnie you're turning red what's going
on
i'm looking at will's eyes and i can see
it right away
will your mother is the best [ __ ] on the
planet according apparently she gets off
the bus and she's ready to be fingered
[Laughter]
[Music]
she gets off bow legged she's waiting
for me
she's the perfect woman she's will with
a [ __ ]
rod he doesn't just rate your mom he has
a whole sexual scenario for every mom
it's a whole fantasy there yeah ronnie
it's fair to say that will's mom is the
one i mean she
is your type like you you know you're
she is my uh catholic school girlfriend
by the way i should tell everyone will's
mom is on a plane in an undisclosed
location
that's right yeah she was a good sport
about the whole thing i let her pick out
her own picture and and uh she said
whatever he says he says so i now
present to you our sixth mom pretty hot
a sexy nose even though it's a little
big but it's very sexy for her face
she could be a lot of fun just the way
she's posing trying to be so innocent i
don't think she's innocent at all man
she's just got this face about the
sexiness
definitely a great [ __ ] definitely a
great [ __ ] there that you could have
a lot of fun with i think she'd like to
she liked to get eaten out you know she
she'd like to just lay there totally
naked
legs spread a kimbo and uh she she would
be
up for anything and a scale of one to
ten i give her an eight
that's gary's mom gary your mom getting
an eight
yeah it's a weird thing because you want
ronnie to like your mom and so like i
was i was actually i'm okay with
everything because he he said what he
would do to her but he didn't call her a
flat out [ __ ] you know so i'm very
happy about that
wait for 30 seconds he sees your mother
rapidly spreading her legs and
enjoying getting eaten out and here's
the weird part my mom and i have the
same face let's not kid ourselves so
ronnie wants to [ __ ] that face and
that's what weirds me out i think she
[ __ ] for
plantains mean thank god she's dead
although i didn't i don't think that
would stop ronnie from trying to [ __ ]
her
all right here's ronnie's evaluation of
our final oh
very very pretty
great eyes i mean i'd love to
i mean back in the day man i'd love to
do it that's for sure this is a type of
girl that you have to date for a while i
think she would be
good wife material there would be great
sex
great blow jobs that's for sure just by
looking at her i mean [ __ ] [ __ ] be
amazing i think she's really hot i would
give on a scale of 110 sex-wise and i'd
give her a nine
nine the highest rating went to the last
mike fox's mom mike mike you've had your
problems with ronnie yes uh ronnie does
not like you never has
cried with him
and then to hear
basically devouring your mother that her
[ __ ] lips that he'd marry her i mean
uh in a way are you proud or you
disgusted so what was going through my
head at the beginning i was like oh this
is what you'd want to hear he's saying
oh great wife material very pretty
want you come to vegas put on a wig and
let me take you to dinner
[Applause]
mike your mom is the only mom that
ronnie's gonna you know he's gonna pay
for dinner
you know
he's going to really work on her the
others he's just taken to bed like poor
will's mom is in the back seat of his
car already
i was counting i think like four out of
the seven moms ronnie said would
probably eat ass so i'm glad to not be
in that category but
i don't know it's still [ __ ] weird
let me recap ronnie gave john blitz mama
five jason's mom is seven wolfy's mom is
seven sal's mom is seven will's mom is
seven point
gary's mom and adam mike fox the big
winners his mom got a nine
and uh thank god we all say that ronnie
never met any of these moms back in the
day he might be your bad guy you might
be
ronnie jr mike munt right
you know i hesitate to say this but
there was one staffer who did show a
picture to ronnie of his mom this guy
withdrew from the competition he
couldn't take it well i'm sorry but uh
you know i didn't know and uh i gave my
personal opinion i'm sorry who do you
think it is ronnie i have no idea i
don't remember well let's not say let's
not say uh wait a
[Music]
second this is uh our our staffer and
one of ronnie's favorites uh mike mike
what happened for you what was the
answer
i really didn't care
the big shot who who likes to do all
kinds of pranks
he [ __ ] he withdrew from it can you
imagine do you want me to play your
ronnie's evaluation of your mom mike i
don't know this one i don't care at this
point you can play it yeah i don't want
to hurt the guy man no it's all right
i'm not like i'm not like him you know
you could play it all right all right
here's ronnie talking about mike she
looks like she's very muscular
small boobs she has very muscular thighs
and arms and
chest
i don't think she would be fun in bed if
she did you know want to do what you
just want to get it over with put it in
let's let's move on let's go back
outside and sit in the sun i would give
her a five
if you think about it i was basically
describing mike because he's the same
way
he's always want to sit in the sun and
be tanned well if i was your mom i would
say she should be proud of that
evaluation ronnie's gonna say uh keep
his hands off her i think that's a good
thing but he wants to have sex with mike
i don't understand yeah no i don't
let's remember that when ronnie was
hypnotized and he was a woman i'm going
to go back in time and play this for you
this is ronnie as angelina
who's the guy on the staff you really
want to [ __ ] tell me what you're
doing
it's just us
you [ __ ] smoking hot
who is smoking hot
who is it
mike
mike pearlman
what would you do to mike pearlman
he's rugged right he's rugged
he's got shot he got shot
mike perlman mike perlman mike perlman
calm down puppet holes mike perlman
what a home run uh well that kind of
wraps it up for ronnie munda's raiding
staff mom i know it may be wrong but
ronnie's raping zappers
this is great